est-ce que vous savez vous pouvez
utiliser votre iPhone comme webcam sur
votre Mac vous pouvez comme ça bien vous
filmer très facilement et lorsque vous
filmez votre Mac ça vous fait un écran
infini et en plus de ça ça marche
lorsque vous le tenez à la verticale
vous le tournez à l'horizontale il se
recalent tout seul pour passer à la
verticale vous le mettez à l'envers il
se remet encore en place alors voilà
comment ça fonctionne sur votre iPhone
vous venez dans vos réglages et dans vos
réglages vous allez ensuite sur général
et vous allez ensuite sur AirPlay et
hand of et vous venez activer en bas
appareil photo continuité ensuite tout
se passe sur votre Mac pour se faire il
faut que vous ayez la dernière version
Mac OS Ventura on va essayer par exemple
avec FaceTime lorsque vous êtes sur
FaceTime vous allez dans vidéo et puis
vous venez choisir votre caméra et vous
voyez que votre iPhone apparaît caméra
de l'iPhone de Aurélien vous cliquez là
vous avez le message directement sur
votre iPhone et vous voyez votre iPhone
est utilisé comme webcam comme ça vous
pouvez venir filmer vos yeux en plein
écran filmez votre nez bref utilisez
votre iPhone comme une webcam